yet sista often bullshit's introduces
the new BMW 7-series the sixth
generation of the luxury sedan you're
always going to expect a lot from a car
like this he says but an ignition key of
this size must mean a load of high-tech
highlights should be interesting BMW
launched the 7 Series almost four
decades ago seven years after the
introduction of the last generation the
new edition is raring to go the
comprehensive revamping says BMW will
mean new benchmarks in handling ride
comfort economy driver assists and
construction
the consequent like a lightweight design
with carbon fiber and other new
materials has meant a significant
reduction in weight combined with a new
suspension system says the BMW spokesman
it gives the car greater agility and far
better handling tannoy elite 8 on dog
leash will be thoroughly cut to bringing
the new 7 series boasts an effective
marriage of performance and comfort yes
finish on Anna Gunn survived the car man
Ralph is very familiar with the 7 Series
and the 6th generation has lost a
further 130 kilos depending on the model
and you certainly notice it it's
extremely fleet-footed and feels more
like a three series or a five series you
can see the typical BMW design
everywhere the trademark kidney grille
has gotten larger the headlights
flattered
the rears hips and the chrome tipped
exhaust pipes underline the car sporty
image
the interior has a luxurious and
spacious feel plush material in an
exclusive and modern touch
the seats promised top-caliber comfort
as you would expect
the enormous legroom in the back
translates into a very nice ride that's
interest of the loin there's a reason
for the ignition key being so big
explains of you can use it to call up
the cars remaining driving range and
perform other functions like remote
parking now synthetic altos altamonte
shine parking yes that means without the
driver just press the display and the
car starts parking itself a very
convenient feature especially when it
comes to tight parking spots
it's on this funny what roof really
likes is the gesture operated music
system if he draws a circle with his
finger the volume goes up move in the
other direction it goes down and if he
points two fingers towards the dash it
will skip to the next track awesome you
can call it gadget rate but just don't
be alarmed if you see a 7 series driver
just tick you lating wildly a move the
other highlights the suspension setup
is a about a 95 BMWs vilified nixle
shows us the driver experience control
switch as with the previous generation
you can choose between a very
comfortable suspension and a sporty-er
option what's new is the adaptive mode
this setting takes into account your
driving style and even the kind of road
or terrain on your route
the beautiful Moines buyers can choose a
long or short version says BMW executive
team or ish in the two biggest Marcus
China and the US long is the only
version available in europe the shorter
version tends to be more popular the
seventh series currently comes with a
range of three engines to gasoline units
and a diesel entry price for a new
seventh series in Germany is eighty-one
thousand nine hundred euros so what does
our car reviewer reckon been via the
sixth generation of the new seven series
is indeed the lightest most dynamic and
most efficient sedan in its class today
I guess Ted Roth has a minor gripe with
the kidney grille a signature design
feature but too flashy for his taste for
manga schmuck the protocol that you know
if I'm an English luck and if you're not
into huge high tech keys you can always
ask for a conventional one after all
it's about the car not the high-tech
touches longer documents will feel
high-tech induces fought against
apartment house Ely Oh car tester montas
kirat asks ever had the urge to break
out of the daily Drudge to pack a few
things and go off somewhere away from
people where nature is still untouched
when he was younger Montes would
probably have hopped on a train with his
backpack today he picked a somewhat more
comfortable alternative the new VW
California annoying for V California
and off we go along the highways and
hair pins of Norway the first California
was designed in 1987 as a budget camper
but the fourth generation is a pretty
sophisticated affair it's based on the
t6 transporter also launched in 2015
this is a van of many talents but
swimming is not one of them as Montes
discovers making his way across Norway's
many fjords finished otha if the road
comes to a watery and says Montes it's
probably better to take the ferry across
as he has done it's a bit chilly so he's
going to turn on the heater to make sure
it's reasonably warm when he gets back
from having a cup of coffee it's like on
it's put me at estimate ensuring the
heisman company on the outside the
California barely differs from the
regular VW van just a few details such
as the roof set this model apart
the ferry crossing takes two hours then
it's time to get in belt up and drive
off don't forget that Montes is on a
quest to find untouched nature when it
comes to mastering the narrow curvy
roads up here the California is a
natural
Islamic by the suspension was already
closed two passenger cars standard in
the California's predecessor explains
Montes the steering's little on the soft
side but overall it's a good ride you
always have the feeling of being in firm
contact with the road our van is powered
by a two-liter 150 kilowatt TDI unit
combined with a 7-speed dual-clutch
gearbox fuel consumption is rated at six
point four liters of diesel for 100
kilometers guns mystic from artists
seating comfort is a big factor when
choosing a camper van and it's decent
enough in the California except it's a
little drafty around the back of the
knees
and so did he go montes ask some locals
which direction camp California is in
[ __ ] they don't seem to understand it of
course the sheep here can only speak
Norwegian right it's probably better to
rely on the onboard sat-nav there aren't
too many side roads to get lost on
anyway these parts montes reaches his
destination just in time for sunset a
little waterfall a meadow a lake and
those civilization as far as the eye can
see now let's take a look inside the
California often esta pelea con see at
first glance the interior hasn't changed
much at all there's still the practical
foldaway table built into the sliding
door and two folding chairs stowed away
in the tailgate and the furnishings look
pretty much the same occurs inside the
kitchen unit is more or less identical
two burners a tiny sink plus a small
refrigerator the buttons on the sliding
doors are a little higher up so that you
can still reach them when the bed is
down it's not run chrome also do and
instead of cotton fabric the roof
bellows are made of polyester the
dashboard is new the heater controls are
the same as the outgoing model time to
close the curtains and call it a night
I will knock my not about not the
morning after Montes reckons those
little changes do make sleeping and
living here in general more comfortable
yes the polyester roof is not soundproof
but that's normal for a camper van he's
no off back to civilization but could
well imagine buying himself a recreation
vehicle like this baby view as an email
via Twitter often lucrative leaders
you'll come to me about two hours for
Stan so an auto-fill I classic often the
last s-class convertible came out in
1971 but at the upcoming international
frankfurt motor show mercedes will be
unveiling the new edition an open-top
affair the s63 AMG with all-wheel drive
makes the dash to 100 km/h and 3.9
seconds the v8 biturbo engine with 430
kilowatts of output has a hefty fuel
economy of ten point four liters per 100
kilometers and a co2 emissions rating of
244 grams
howdy will likewise be in Frankfort with
a new edition of the a4 Avant the
horizontal contouring at the front and
rear give the station wagon a wider look
than its predecessor the body as with
the q7 is part aluminum that saves
weight and boost fuel economy the cargo
area has 500 5 litres of space the new
model offers a choice of seven engines
prices for the 1.4 tfsi edition start at
thirty two and a half thousand euros in
Germany
the legendary nurburgring recently
hosted the world endurance championship
for the very first time the WEC is the
second most popular racing series after
Formula One teams compete and eight
races on four continents for the title
Porsche joint just last year almost is
that's almost we thought about which
event was the right one for the company
and soon came across the sports
prototypes Porsche used to take part in
those races it's a lot of fun for the
spectators and the team because of the
similarity to road-going editions for
now porsche has decided to take part
through to 2018 and everyone is really
excited about it the World Endurance
Championship divides cars into four
categories lamont prototype one is the
top class innovation is the name of the
game energy recovery systems built into
each car maximize engine efficiency
porsche entered two cars in the race
number 17 at 18 in car 17 Timo Ben hunt
Brendon Hartley and former Formula One
driver Mark Webber
I think the first few races and then
also last year WEC is getting very
interesting the cars are sensational to
watch on track their sexy they're fast
so I think the people know that you know
435 euro they have a ticket for all
weekend and they have this access it's a
very very hard opportunity not to come
and see the cars and what's the racing
porsche dominated at the qualifiers at
the Nurburgring after winning in lamont
in June the car maker decided to revamp
the bodies of its 919 hybrids for the
five remaining races the new design has
helped push performance even further
Portia beat its nearest competitor audi
with more than a second to spare toyota
came trailing a full 2 seconds behind
Porsches research and development
director was happy with the result
I think we showed a great performance we
are confident going forward the long
runs yesterday and today we're good I
think we have set ourselves up well for
tomorrow where we can start from the
front I also think tomorrow will get a
bit tighter but we will do everything we
can to stay in the lead water what it's
about before the final race drivers take
a timeout for the fans lined up to meet
their heroes in person and maybe even
have a chat or snap a selfie with a star
the stands fill up in anticipation for
the competition the 6-hour enduro thon
starts out with Porsche at the front car
18 enjoys a comfortable lead ahead of
the pack but a problem with the gas tank
jeopardizes its chances of a win a
broken sensor is relaying incorrect
information and the hybrid 919 starts
using too much gas the WEC has strict
rules on fuel consumption
the first warning comes with a
five-second penalty repeat offenders
have to wait 30 seconds in the pits the
third penalty is a crushing 60 second
penalty precious time and a race where
every second counts mechanics aren't
allowed to work on the car when it is
parked in the sin bin a serious setback
and a hard lesson for the R&D chief
oh yeah the boost pressure sensor moved
and then we had a problem with
establishing the right amount of
pressure which resulted in excess boost
the car used too much fuel twice we
still have to talk with the race
organizers the third stop-and-go penalty
wasn't fair but it all still worked down
for us by the end what's waiting after
six hours of concentrated driving number
17 crosses the line first
I know
Portia wins the first world endurance
championship race hosted by the
Nurburgring and not far behind with an
impressive piece of catching up number
18 take second spot applause all around
a Porsche 919 driver Mark Weber says it
was a hard win
ya need to be fully concentrated I think
that um the start of the race for us was
a bit tricky with some damage on the car
and then we hung in there then obviously
a teen had some problems with some fuel
flow problems and so yeah and then what
you never have LD out of the game you
know she have to stay concentrated but
in the end I think was a good result it
was a great one too obviously and I mean
of course it's a good result but I
finally for us on 17 we had a little bit
of I think we deserve the weekly we've
had a few races where we've been leaving
and not having the result with the
reliability now we had a great race
it was one of automotive history's odd
men out exploring the Italian Alps in an
eccentric vintage car is a rare
experience the cord 812 looks a bit like
the caffeine fit of a madcap designer or
maybe like a masterpiece by a brilliant
automobile tycoon
eret lovin as Kurt istic ustav Bauer
tells us hardly anyone knows arrêt loban
cords named today but he was a shining
example of the American dream he started
small as a gas station attendant and car
salesman and worked his way up to become
owner of the auburn and Duesenberg car
makers two of the most renowned car
companies of the time in 1929 he
launched a third company named after
himself cord automobiles as a young but
experienced entrepreneur Erin Logan cord
should have put the wishes and needs of
his customers first but he didn't he
used the cord automobile to experiment
to build a car that would be new and
different
from an pho hung from the beginning cord
stood out for its striking design and
innovative technologies in 1929
front-wheel-drive made its American
debut in the first chord model the l-29
the 812 SC also put the power on the
front axle practically unheard of at the
time but the powerful turbocharged v8
engine quickly pushed the narrow tires
to the limits of their traction the cord
had trouble handling tight curves even
so it was one of the fastest cars of its
day Thomas students nezzie I an auto
stabbed it with the help of its
streamlined body the cord 812 SC
achieved a top speed of 160 km/h the
original advertising brochure boasted
that the reduction of drag was a crucial
factor a new concept at the time like
most of the courts technical components
zenko krista describes the cord is a
dream for beginning drivers if they
happen to stall the cords engine the
driver just had the step on the clutch
and it automatically started again and
it's shifted with a flick of a finger
the pneumatic pre-selected transmission
tiptoe through the three gears plus
overdrive semi-automatically and at a
time when few cars even had windshield
wipers the cord had variable speed
wipers it was the first car with a radio
as standard equipment and hidden
headlights in the 1930s that was as
sophisticated as technology got Vasa
what a mean nose says Christa that's the
impression this court must have made at
the time with its massive wraparound
chrome grille the pop-up headlights and
above all these chrome external pipes
and these are caught off that worth
forget the car must have seemed like
some bizarre insect from a faraway
galaxy galaxy Gordon burek a
world-famous industrial designer at the
time put little value on understatement
but a lot of elegance and aerodynamics
genomic la danza Mia this was one of the
first cars with door hinges mounted
inside till then they'd always been
sticking out looking a bit clunky the
design of the cord was a perfect dream
but only its design designed music
in the 1930s the cord 812 and it's
optically identical predecessor the 810
revolutionized American automotive
design with its harmonious and sweeping
lines the three hearts in the logo were
said to stand for e l cords love for his
cars that's easy to believe given the
breathtaking detail of this work of art
on wheels the fine a woman of dashboard
with easily readable instruments the
filigree shifting gate the many sculpted
lovers and dignified club atmosphere
show chords automotive vision extends
into the interior as well the cords
pop-up headlights the first in any
production car anywhere did not become a
common sight till 30 years later the
function of the hood is what gave the
cord the nickname coffin knows it
enclosed a v8 engine made by lycoming
one of the leading American aircraft
engine builders normally it put out some
125 horsepower but this SC version with
a schwitzer kuvings centrifugal
supercharger achieved 170 horsepower and
a top speed of 160 km/h faster than
almost any other production car at the
time
in combination with the superchargers
hum the v8 and its 4.7 liter capacity
produced an unparalleled sound on the
outside the cord is an eye catcher and a
half but under the hood it was fraught
with problems by sign up hasn't and its
debut at the 1935 New York Auto Show the
cord 812 caused a sensation everybody
rushed to see the masterpiece of design
and hundreds of pre-orders came pouring
in but the cord was simply not ready for
production not by a long shot as so
often happens when things are rushed
things go wrong the first models were
delivered in 1936 but the many technical
bugs soon made the dream car a complete
nightmare the cords engine was prone to
overheating the transmission to jumping
out of gear and the cooling system to
leaking and it's nearly 1.7 tons proof
far less manageable than the dynamic
design made it appear in just eight
years cord at gone bust
flight record Christophe concludes that
the cord may have been one of America's
most innovative makes but it was also
certainly one of its most short-lived
even so it was a good 30 years ahead of
its time and design aerodynamics and
technology but as so often with
innovators their true value is often
only recognized when it's too late today
it's obvious the cord 812 was a
milestone in automotive history inch
Diamond Dallas will be assistant only
about 3,000 cord 812 s were ever built
134 them as the coveted supercharged SC
version the cord took its sisters Auburn
and Duesenberg down with it what's left
is the beauty the elegance and the dream
you